a mandatory evacuation of the New York
comedy club took place last night after
an unusual Moment On Stage that still
has people scratching their heads uh-oh
oh boy hey anything can happen to the
comedy show things first start getting
weird when this random guy wanders on
stage looking lost and scared Mark
Norman tosses out a few zingers trying
to keep the situation light until
security escorts this man off stage
where things get very strange however is
immediately after this Mark was then
told to get off stage without giving any
sort of explanation which left the crowd
in a state of confusion until this
announcement was made guys everything's
fine um we just had a
momentary Interruption um just stay get
up get out the the taping um can we get
out or what the camera yeah I'm one of
the producers of the show um yeah we
just need everybody take get out please
nice and slow everything's fine as of
now people still don't really know
exactly why